Someone just sent me a DM,
and she said that her ex is starting to call her
with the new girlfriend in the background,
and they're, like,
talking shit and, like,
antagonizing her and, like,
giving her a fucking hard time.
She's like, it's wild because I watch your video,
so I understood what they were gonna do.
And it's like, kind of funny watching it.
And here's the thing. Here's like,
the next best part about that.
Branny Brown,
who is a researcher in emotions at the university of Texas,
like, her whole fucking life
is dedicated to researching feelings and emotions
and everything about feelings.
She has said that
two people coming together for the hatred of one thing
will be united for a little bit.
You can totally find a unity in two people hating the same thing.
But you will not find longevity with that.
Like, that's not the kind of.
You can't base a long term commitment on that.
That's not. That's not the proper foundation for long term,
healthy longevity, like,
healthy, fueled relationships.
So when that happens, number one,
you're like, okay, cool.
Got it. You guys are definitely off to the same toxic start,
whether you. You know what I mean?
And you can, like,
secretly laugh inside cause you're like,
y'all are bonding over your hate
over me not understanding that once you realize I'm not gonna react,
I'm not gonna participate. Like,
okay, have your happiness and hate for me.
And you keep living your happy life,
their relationship just crumbles
because it's all based on just trying to hate you.
So you just, like, truly,
truly, truly
the best revenge, the best win, win,
win, win,
win situation for everything. Everybody. Everything. Children,
pets, parents.
Great. Everybody to move forward in your own life happy and healthy
and not give a fuck what people are saying about you.
Because the truth always comes out, like,
and. But.
And ugly people are gonna be drawn to ugly people.
Like, you can't help that.
Ugly people still have friends.
Do you know what I mean? There are shitty people that are like,
I know that person shitty,
and that's why I wanna be their friend.
And it's the perfect, like,
strainer for your life. You just rise above
and all the everybody else, like,
sticks together. You find your people.
It's great. It's. It's great.